bonjour à tous et toutes aujourd'hui
nous faisons face à une situation
extrêmement tendue sur la question du
logement rappelle qu'on a quand même 3
millions via l'outil 3,6 millions de
personnes mal logées dans notre pays je
suis très heureuse de vous présenter ce
projet de loi qui vient d'être présenté
en conseil des ministres cette mesure
qui est proposé aujourd'hui est attendu
par de nombreux territoires va forcer
les maires des communes où il fait bon
jour à faire les mêmes des coûts le fait
qu'on l'a fait dans les années 60 70
il
on enlève les chaussures on va sur la
gueule et n'a donc on a un long couloir
qui sert à stocker met à faire des bébés
la cuisine ou cas relativement grand les
toilettes et la chambre maguelone habite
dans un petit et trois à paris avec la
famille qui s'est progressivement
agrandi
l'appartement est devenu trop petit ces
deux garçons partagent déjà la même
pièce et l'arrivée du troisième inquiète
c'est la jeune maman dans cette étagère
des dizaines de dossiers de visite
ça c'est ce qu'on a visités avec un à
chaque fois des refus malgré deux
salaires corrects l'appartement qu'on y
cellou et c'est quand même 4000 euros de
frais d'agencé six mois en mois de
caution et six mois de caution bancaire
quoi n'en est pas sûre d'être aux prises
maguelone et sa famille sont aussi
éligibles à un logement social
son premier dossier elle l'a déposé
voilà dix ans chaque année enrôlant son
renvoi le c'est l'avis d'imposition je
crois qu'on doit renvoyer chaque année
pour recevoir la lettre en noir mais bon
on n'a pas une nouvelle comme
l'appartement nous a proposé 0
appartement
à l'image de maguelone et quel que soit
le niveau de revenu un million et demi
de personnes sont en attente d'un
logement social et 10 millions auraient
des difficultés à se loger
constat d'échec des politiques
successives en faveur de la construction
la séance est ouverte en matière de
construction il y à un texte clé nous
sommes en avril 2000 la loi dite sru est
adoptée par le parlement et ses rues
pour solidarité et renouvellement urbain
sa mesure principale imposé aux communes
de plus de 3500 habitants de construire
20% de logements sociaux en 20 ans c'est
dire l'effort de la collectivité
nationale pour donner andrew un toit et
les conditions de vie décentes à une
majorité de nos concitoyens jugées trop
contraignantes par les élus locaux
cette loi sera régulièrement attaquée et
en 2006 ce sera même le dernier combat
de l'abbé pierre
à 93 ans il vient défendre le texte dans
la tribune de l'assemblée
c'est jean marc ayrault alors député
dans l'opposition qui l'accueille ce
jour là ne voulons pas qu'on touche à la
règle des 20 % de logements sociaux dans
toutes les communes merci de votre appui
mes chers collègues je salue la présence
parmi le public de notre ancien collègue
henri grouès plus connu sous le nom de
l'abbé pierre
l'honneur c'est quand le fort s'applique
aide est le moins fort a aidé le faible
l'appel sera entendu la loi appliquée
mais si l'on a près la situation en
matière de logement reste toujours
tendue
ce mercredi 5 septembre 2012 cécile
duflot vient présenter le plan du
gouvernement avec un objectif en tête y
construire 500 mille logements par an
dont 150 mille logements sociaux donc ce
projet de loi deux volets de volée qui
permettront comme son nom l'indiqué une
mobilisation générale en faveur du
logement par un versant flück incitatif
inversons assez déterminant qui est la
cession du foncier public de l'état et
de ses opérateurs jusqu'à la possibilité
d'une avec une possibilité de décote qui
pourra aller jusqu'à la gratuité pour la
construction de logements et en
particulier logements sociaux mais un
autre volet ce volet qui renforce la loi
qui s'appelle la loi sru qui fera passer
devant à 25 % le seuil de logements
sociaux nécessaires et obligatoires par
communes de plus de 3500 habitants
en clair l'état s'engage à libérer des
terrains parfois gratuitement une liste
en recense 900 au total et pour les
mères leurs obligations sont donc
augmenter ceux qui ne respecteront pas
cet objectif de 25% seront plus
sévèrement sanctionné sur les 36000
communes de france je pense qu'il y en a
moins de 1000 qui revendique pour
certains d'entre eux d'être hors la loi
alors que beaucoup d'autres quelle que
soit leur étiquette politique participe
de cette mission d'intérêt général qui
est de construire du logement social
donc effectivement ceux qui s'obstinent
feront l'objet de sanctions qui seront
des sanctions
renforcée puisque elles seront
multipliées par cinq
henri plagnol est l'un de ces mauvais
élèves 20 ou 25 % de logements sociaux
dans sa commune le député maire de
saint-maur des fossés s'y oppose et le
revendique
je ne refuserai pas lapidée loin mais
elle veut pas refuser d'appliquer la loi
j'userai de tous les moyens juridiques
pour jusqu'au bout combattent cette
logique qui n'est pas efficace
on ne créera pas un logement de plus et
tout le monde le sait et qui est
attentatoire aux principes fondamentaux
de notre démocratie
henri plagnol le sait les pénalités
existantes sont peu contraignantes
facilement réduite en fonction des
efforts consentis en quatre ans
saint-maur des fossés par exemple passer
de 5 à 7 % de logements sociaux
suffisant pour échapper à ces pénalités
au sénat les auditions sur le texte
commence
bernard lacharme et le secrétaire
général du haut comité pour le logement
des personnes défavorisées cession de
foncier public augmentation des
objectifs et des pénalités pour les
mères pour lui le texte va dans le bon
sens
encore faut-il le faire appliquer ici
comme cela se passait les années
précédentes les préfets en reste là et
que certains maires acceptent de payer
les amendes on ne résout pas les
problèmes
les préfet dispose du pouvoir de faire
construire les logements sociaux sur les
territoires où il ya des obligations
donc ça c'est aussi la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est ce qu'on attend de
lui que de faire appliquer totalement la
loi
bonjour je m'explique de bronze dans les
retards mais on avait un peu de retard
claude bérit-debat et le rapporteur du
texte au sénat
il a deux jours pour auditionner les
principaux acteurs du logement
voilà dont je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation d'audition
bon s'agit bien entendu de nous entendre
sur le projet de loi qui concerne le
vraiment quels sont les aspects du texte
qui apparaissent positif et a contrario
qu est-ce qu il ya des des problèmes des
points qui ne vous le satisfont pas et
troisième point de plus à prendre
dans le détail quelles sont
les points de ce projet de loi qui selon
vous mérite serait d'être complété deux
jours d'auditions au lieu de plusieurs
semaines habituellement c'est la
première fois qu'un projet de loi est
étudiée au parlement dans des délais
aussi courts qu'on ait place le
gouvernement veut aller vite
au lendemain de la conférence de presse
de cécile duflot le rapporteur au sénat
se lance dans une course contre la
montre
ça fait partie des joies du travail de
rapporteur le temps passé contre m
puis est important de recevoir d'écouté
d'échangés avec des acteurs précise aux
principaux que sont les collectivités et
les représentants des collectifs
représentants de la msa représentants
des communes urbaines représentants de
la vie cf bref non seulement les
collectivités mais également les acteurs
qui interviennent directement à la
construction du logement
bonjour jean marc roger est le directeur
immobilier de la sncf
jusque là son cahier des charges était
clair tirer le meilleur prix de terrains
inutilisés depuis 2011 on a vendu un peu
plus de 1 milliard d'actifs immobiliers
en termes de produits de cession et
danser un milliard bien sûr il ya eu
toutes sortes d'opérations des bâtiments
l'état des et parmi eux des fonciers une
trentaine d'hectares qui ont été
concernés concrètement par des
opérations de logement
si la loi est adoptée la sncf devra
consentir une forte décote sur la vente
de ces terrains destinés à accueillir
des programmes d'immobilier plus ces
programmes prévoiront de logements
sociaux et plus la décote sera forte
cet effort qui nous sera demandé sur la
partie sociale des programmes urbains
doit pouvoir trouver facilement une
compensation intelligente dans le reste
du programme d'aménagement de ces
foncière question même logique
économique pour réseau ferré de france
tous deux dépendent du ministère des
transports un ministère avec ses propres
impératifs deux opérateurs avec de
fortes contraintes financières
je crois qu'une première chose pour
qu'ils paient la compréhension entre
nous c'est que notre intérêt n'est
évidemment pas garder les terrains qu'il
nous conte un terrain n'a pas d' usage
ferroviaire
le bon sens c'est de le vendre est ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
nos tutelles
évidemment nous mettre constamment la
pression pour que nous vendions le
terrain qui n'a pas des terrains qui
n'ont pas dû la jeter robière voilà
parce que c'est notamment ce qui
contribue à financer l'effort de
rénovation du réseau qui est qui est
monté en puissance depuis depuis deux
trois ans si la sncf s'inquiète de
l'idée de gratuité de certaines
parcelles face caméra rff ne s'y
opposent pas nous sommes déjà mobilisés
nous ont bien sûr amplifié cette
mobilisation pour aller plus vite et
puis offrir des conditions financières
plus intéressantes et donc si le projet
la commune c'est du logement social si
logement social est bien une priorité
politique
eh bien nous irons jusqu à 100 % comme
les textes le prévoient malgré la bonne
volonté affichée
la réalité serait bien différente les
réticences pour vendre à bas prix
fréquentes direction l'est de la france
martial bourquin et le sénateur maire
d'audincourt avec un taux de logements
sociaux dépassant les 30 %
la ville fait partie des très bons
élèves de la loi sru m'aguerrir la gare
alors ça c'est non seulement sur l'année
un placard david comme ça
sur le territoire de sa commune l'un des
neuf cents terrains identifiés par le
ministère du logement
ce terrain le voici une friche de 5
hectares est laissé à l'abandon
bonjour monsieur alors césar patients
bien vous aussi
ben justement dont on en parle en valeur
ont comme on l'a on veut acheter
j'ai rendez-vous dans les jours qui
viennent avec les reflex est l'idée
c'est de faire un éco quartier mais
surtout regarder dans l'état où sais
c'est pas possible ça reste comme ça
les négociations avec rff dure depuis
plusieurs années la municipalité
souhaite acheter ce terrain mais le prix
demandé est trop élevé les cons quartier
espérer fait pourtant une large place à
des logements sociaux domaine ont évalué
à 80 et 90 euros le mètre carré
ensuite sont tombés après discussion à
50 et j'étais à 25 derniers avouent
dernier comme je fais dit une fois on
était un peu dans la vérité si jours
c'était assez vague on peut vouloir
vendre un terrain comme celui d'un prix
pareil parce qu'il faut savoir qu'une
fois ce terrain acheté dépolluer le plus
dur reste à faire pour investir
plusieurs millions d'euros pour le
rendre habitable en place et c'est pour
cela que il était dommage que l'état
bloc des parcelles comme ça mais je sais
que ça se fait dans plusieurs villes de
france avec que le projet de loi discuté
au parlement
la donne pourrait changer rff auraient
l'obligation de vendre de vendre vite et
avec une forte décote sont des
discussions sans fin j'en veux temps
l'administration n'est pas s'intéresser
pour le vendre immédiatement et là je
pense que pour audincourt mais aussi
pour de nombreuses villes ça va être
l'occasion de débloquer les dossiers
comme en retour à paris nous sommes dans
le 12e arrondissement jean marc ayrault
et cécile duflot ont donné rendez-vous à
la presse à la caserne de reuilly
c'est un des sites appelés à accueillir
un programme de logements sociaux ou
voit ici l'ensemble des bâtiments
historiques et c'est à peu près à la
moitié des logements qui sont réalisés
en réhabilitation
le premier ministre est là pour défendre
le texte et l'urgence de son adoption
une visite sur fond de polémique la
liste de terrain présenté deux jours
plus tôt par la ministre se révèle très
imparfaite
sur les 900 foncier identifié certains
seraient déjà vendu d'autres
indisponibles
le gouvernement est accusé de
précipitations que tu un changement
d'objectif c'est un changement
d'ambition mais c'est aussi un
changement de méthode et donc il y a des
conservatismes il ya des résistances au
point d'ailleurs que je voyais une liste
publiée par france domaine qui
correspond pas tout à fait à notre
commande est bien là aussi des choses
changeront je le paie par les personnes
en cause
je dis simplement que la culture
précédente c'était surtout ne donnez pas
les terrains mais si c'est pour du
logement social
wendel est pour faire davantage de
recettes pour l'état pouvait se
comprendre mais c'était une autre
logique
donc il faut tourner cette page
dans le collimateur de jean marc ayrault
les services de france domaine chargée
de gérer le patrimoine de l'état
alors simple erreur administrative ou
vraie réticence au sénat le cabinet de
la ministre du logement attend d'être
auditionnés visiblement c'est la
compréhension avoir comme un bleu
dernière audition au sénat
comme beaucoup d'associations la
fondation abbé-pierre défend le texte
même si cette loi ne doit être qu'une
première étape
c'est une première un premier étage de
la fusée qui comprend beaucoup des
tâches pour résoudre la crise du
logement financé cent cinquante mille
logements sociaux réguler les prix des
loyers permettre à la baisse permettent
de les faire baisser ces loyers tout un
débat aussi sur la mobilisation du parc
privé
si on veut construire 500 mille
logements il va falloir des mesures pour
booster cette construction
parce que s'il n'y a pas ce travail de
construction massive durable on
continuera à avoir un déficit comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et donc des
effets d'exclusion prairies de bonnes au
final en deux jours le rapporteur aura
auditionné une quinzaine d'acteurs du
logement élus promoteur offices hlm
unanimement ils se fait si j'ai su
félicite des dispositions contenues dans
la loi dans sa quelque chose c'est une
unanimité à retenir est à souligner
après chacun en fonction de des
instances qui représentent ils ont des
jurés des remarques à faire pour
améliorer le dispositif dont je
proposerai un certain nombre
d'amendements en commissions qui seront
effectivement proposé en sciences et
puis on étudiera ensuite les amendements
de nos collègues qui ne vont pas manquer
d'ail et dans un certain nombre de
domaines
en pratique le rapporteur doit
maintenant rédiger un texte et c'est ce
texte de la commission qui est ensuite
débattu en séance
problème les délais imposés par le
gouvernement sont trop courts la séance
a lieu dans trois jours il n'ya pas
texte comme ici on orient à prendre
non pas aux appels déjà là vous allez
bon ça c'est sûr c'est matériellement
pas possible
en fait c'est bien compris mais bon ça
et surtout s'il s'agit alors il ya un
rap taux qui seront mis en rapport aux
halles du rapporteur
il sera apprécié rapport au locle
deviendra écrit et après les amendements
seront examinés en série présence et
revoilà honnêtement si on était mieux de
conclure c'est comme ça voilà c'est vrai
sur la forme ça vole à l'envoi discuter
pendant des heures mais je pense que
alors que sur le décor opérationnel
rapidement ses 50 jours mais je suis
d'accord avec toi bon écoute
elle donnera mardi matin merci à bientôt
il est passé par là
benoist apparu a été le dernier ministre
du logement dans le gouvernement de
françois fillon ce matin au sénat
il est attendu par le groupe ump pour
une rencontre de travail sur le projet
de loi en faveur du logement
pour jean claude gaudin c'est d'abord la
forme qui dérange plus que le fond
le sénat n'a pas l'habitude de
travailler comme ça sous la pression les
exigences du gouvernement
ici nous sommes une assemblée qui a la
réputation de prendre sans tarder de la
sagesse de l'expérience la compétence
regardez ce matin même alors que le
texte arrive cet après midi à 15h en
discussion il ya deux réunions de la com
des commissions compétentes une qui se
tient à l'instant mais mulhouse qui se
tiendra à vide c'est pas du bon travail
et nous demandons au président belle de
faire en sorte que le sénat puisse se
travailler d'une manière apaisée et
profitable à l'intérêt des princesses
des français l'ancien ministre du
logement a d'abord rappelé un bilan 130
mille logements sociaux en moyenne
chaque année durant le précédent
quinquennat s'il partage les objectifs
du nouveau texte
certaines dispositions inquiètent
pendant une heure les sénateurs
préparent leurs éléments de langage leur
ligne d'attaqué pour les débats prévus
dans l'après midi
ce n'est pas un texte lequel on aura une
imposition lourdes farouche des
sénateurs ump
parce qu'il ya des éléments positifs
dans ce texte de loi mais comme tout le
diable se niche dans les détails le 20 à
25 % de logements sociaux on peut être
d'accord
le calendrier proposé est d'une
absurdité complète donc on peut être
d'accord sur un objectif et un principe
mais sur les modalités d'application se
dire non la modalité d'application est
véritablement dangereuse deux étages
plus haut la commission de l'économie
réunis autour du rapporteur du texte
claude bérit-debat présente sa synthèse
après les auditions et surtout les
amendements qu'il souhaite apporter au
projet de loi c
l'acteur de la mise en place de la mise
en route du projet de loi
comme vous le savez tous les titres 1 et
2 du projet de loi vise à mettre en
oeuvre des engagements forts du
président de la république en matière de
logement avec la construction de 5000
logements par an dont 150 mille
logements sociaux vous comprenez donc
qu'au terme du nez travaux j'estime
qu'en tant que rapporteur que ce texte
constitue une avancée importante
je vous procure proposerait tout à
l'heure une dizaine d'amendements dans
aucune membres sur l'équilibré le
rapporteur veut par exemple imposé la
gratuité comme principe lors de la vente
des terrains publics et assurer un
minimum de logements très sociaux dans
les futurs projets immobiliers
nous ne seront pas autorisés à suivre
les débats mais les échanges seront vifs
entre sénateurs de la majorité et
d'opposition
monsieur le président
le 21e siècle sera-t-il celui de la
civilisation urbaine
c'est avec cette interrogation qui lie à
12 ans jean claude gayssot était venu
présenter la loi solidarité
renouvellement urbain devant le
parlement
aujourd'hui en ce 11 septembre 2012
le texte que je vous présente n'est ni
une loi pour la ville ni une loi pour
les campagnes
ce n'est pas non plus une loi pour le
bâti ou pour l'urbain c'est tout
simplement une loi pour l'humain alors
le gouvernement est il allé trop vite
plusieurs recours visant à l'annulation
de la procédure sont déposés par
l'opposition après vote
tous sont rejetés colère sur les bancs
de l'ump
le vrai sujet quand on est au parlement
quand on respecte la constitution
quand on a des institutions
républicaines c'est de les respecter
parce que si même ça vous les bafouez si
même ça vous les foulées aux pieds
comment demain sur d'autres textes avec
d'autres gouvernements avec d'autres
majorités vous allez vous faire
respecter les débats sur le fond vont
durer deux jours et deux nuits plus de
160 amendements est un principal point
de désaccord le seuil de 25 % de
logement social ou plutôt le délai pour
l'atteindre fixé à 2025
le scénario que vous proposez n'est pas
tenable
je vais prendre un exemple concret d'une
commune qui d'ici 12 ans souhaite
répondre à l'ensemble des besoins de sa
population et donc développer une offre
diversifiée
cette commune iranienne le sol et est
une commune de 7000 habitants
pour bien comprendre ces inquiétudes
direction sa ville du soleil dans
l'agglomération de perpignan
en 2007 le taux de logement social net
est ici que de 3%
la commune paient alors 38000 euros de
pénalités
depuis le sénateur maire a lancé un
vaste programme immobilier
finalement dans cette ville en aura en
cinq ans multiplier par cinq le nombre
des loges
sociaux grâce bien sûr à la
collaboration avec l'agglomération la
région et l'état bien sûr et ça nous
permet d'ailleurs d'aider d'échapper aux
pénalités de la loi sru voilà c'est
aussi très important puisque c'est les
pénalités qui porte sur le budget de
fonctionnement
ce nouveau quartier le voici avec des
logements sociaux mais pas seulement
on a rattrapé notre retard petit à petit
un augmenta le pourcentage en restant
calmes donne des choses raisonnables
puisque il ya une harmonie impeccable ce
lotissement fonctionne maintenant depuis
trois ans françois calvet a fait son
calcul
25 % de logements sociaux d'ici à 2025
cet objectif fixé par la loi ne serait
pas tenable pour sa commune regardez ici
pour faire les 120 logements que que
nous venons de réaliser et nous a fallu
quatre ans il faut que j'en fasse six
ans pour répondre à la loi sru à 25% 600
mhz en 12 ans je ne les ferai pas
jaffray 300 j'en ferais pas six ans ce
qu'elle veut mais à vouloir trop poussé
il faudrait pas qu'on tombe dans les
ghettos
c'est à dire qu'on produise 80 % de
logements sociaux et 20 % de résidences
principales
là ça peut ça peut déraper quoi pour
échapper à la pénalité puisque multiplie
les pénalités par 5 je le rappelle que
ces pénalités peuvent représenter 10% du
budget de fonctionnement de la commune
est ici ça peut aller jusqu'à 6 à 1000
euros
donc voilà ça ce serait dans l'absurde
mais enfin l'absurde est prévue par la
loi
une partie de ces 300 logements sociaux
se feront sur ce terrain les travaux
viennent de commencer
mais au delà des délais c'est aussi le
financement qui selon le sénateur maire
va manquer rien que sur l'agglomération
de perpignan
il faudrait que l'état soutienne la
construction de 18 mille logements pour
respecter la future loi c'est pas les
savait millions d'euros du fonds de
l'agencé nationale qui vont permettre de
réussir ce pari qui est un pari
ambitieux intéressant mais à mon avis il
ya quand même beaucoup de choses qu'on
doit compléter en séance et en guise de
réponse la ministre l'a souvent rappelé
ce texte n'est qu'une première étape
après deux jours de débats son projet de
loi est adopté par le sénat malgré
l'opposition du centre et de l'ump un
amendement du rapporteur vient même
renforcer la notion de gratuité des
fonciers publics contre l'avis du
gouvernement le texte est donc adoptée
dans la même liste vous souhaitez la
parole je voudrais simplement remercier
l'ensemble des sénateurs et des
sénatrices qui ont participé à la
discussion de ce projet de loi j'ai été
très sensible à l'intérêt que vous avez
porté effectivement dans des conditions
peut-être un petit peu difficile mais il
ya eu quand même un travail sur le fond
très intéressant et ça n'était qu'une
première étape puisque je pense au
travail
non mais c'est réussi en plus avaient
plutôt ça s'était bien fait
il ya des choses que tu tiennes d'une
chute à sarno s'agit bien je tiens
surtout l inversion un amendement ump
contre l'avis du gouvernement
c'est à dire la décôte d'annoncer sa
force en supprimant le tout simplement
de permettre au président de la
république de tenir ses engagements
moi je porte la vie au gouvernement est
une discipline de fer ont déçu même
quand tu penses pas je ne peux que
m'estimer très très satisfait de ce vote
de ce premier projet de loi sur le grand
de bronze
national d'urgence nationale qu'est le
logement
deux semaines plus tard à l'assemblée le
texte n'est pas adopté dans les mêmes
termes
c'est une commission mixte réunissant 7
sénateurs et 7 députés qui doit parvenir
à un compromis
il ya tout l'art et le tableau
comparatif des textes votés par le sénat
d'abord et là ça me met ensuite
et voilà les articles qui posent
problème après mandela il n'y a pas de
point d'achoppement sur le coeur du
sujet enfin on a des discussions mais
qui sont vraiment la discussion de
détail principales modifications
apportées au texte initial les communes
entre 1500 et 3500 habitants ont
désormais l'obligation d'atteindre les
10 % de logement social cette
disposition ne concerne que les communes
situées sur de grandes agglomérations
l'idée du rapporteur de faire de la
gratuité des fonciers un principe est en
revanche rejeté à la sortie claude
bérit-debat se montre pourtant satisfait
il y à un compromis qui sortis entre les
propositions du sénat la loi qui est
telle qu'elle a été votée au sénat et
celle qu'elle a été votée à l'assemblée
nationale mission accomplie voilà